In the last couple of lectures, we've looked
at the process of image formation, that's
how we transform the 3D world, into a two-dimensional
image or representation of that world. The
actual three-dimensional structure of the
world is really, really important, for animals
as well as for robots. So in the case of animals,
if you image that you are a predatory animal,
it's really important to know how far away
the prey is. If you're a prey animal it's
really important to know how far away the
predator is. If you're a robot, you might
want to know how far away is the object that
you want to reach and grab. If you're a mobile
robot, you want to know which parts of the
space in front of you have got objects sticking
up above the ground, that prevent you from
driving there and which parts of the world
are free from those kinds of obstacles.
So we want to have a three dimensional structure
of the world, but we've only got a two dimensional
representational projection. How do we solve
this problem? When human beings look at a
two dimensional image or a photograph, we
imagine the three dimensional structure and
that comes from our experience of 3D worlds,
the experiences that we've gain through our
whole lives. And I'm going to talk a little
bit about some of the mechanism by which human
beings fill in this missing dimension. In
particular I'm going to talk about binocular
stereo and that's how we take information
from two cameras, like the two eyes that we
have in our heads and recreate three dimensional
world from that. And this is a very common
technique in robotics called "Stereo Vision".